hey remember when Joe Biden said that he
had never talked to his son Hunter about
hunter's corrupt overseas business
dealings
president how many
have you ever spoken to your son about
his overseas business dealings I've
never spoken to my son about his
overseas I have never discussed with my
son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period And what I will do is
the same thing we did in our
Administration there will be an absolute
wall between personal and private uh and
and the government do you stand by your
statement that you did not discuss any
of your son's overseas business yes I
stand by that statement I did not know
he was on the board of that company I've
never discussed my business or their
business my sons or daughters but I
never discussed a single thing with my
son about anything having to do with
Ukraine
no okay well turns out all those many
times Joe said that it was all a lie
that story fell apart after Hunter
accidentally admitted in print first and
then later in a filmed interview the
very words that Joe said while they were
talking about his business deals
did you and your father ever discuss
Ukraine no as I said the only time was
after a news account and it wasn't a
discussion in any way there's no but to
this no we never did your dad said I
hope you know what you're doing I hope
you know what you're doing I do and I
said I do and that was literally the end
of our discussion
that was it no we never ever talked
about it once the only time was hold on
no there's no but no sorry I we know we
never talked about it but you said you
talked about it yeah okay we talked
about it but it was it was just it was a
little bit it wasn't a lot so okay then
the story was they talked about the
business deals but only briefly
and nobody believed that story either
but that story officially fell apart
yesterday when Hunter's business partner
Devin Archer testified behind closed
doors that Joe not only spoke to Hunter
about the Crooked deals but was in fact
present on phone calls on which the
Crooked deals were being ironed out
a bunch of details on specific calls are
available in all sorts of news reports
from yesterday the evidence is
apparently so damning that Democrats
aren't even trying to deny it so the
best story they've come up with now care
of democrat Congressman Daniel Goldman
is okay Biden knew about the deals and
okay Biden talked about the deals with
Hunter and okay Biden was actually on
the phone calls talking to the crooks
with whom Hunter was making the deals
but
they only talked about the weather
so to confirm you're saying that the
speakerphone conversations they don't
seem concerning to you because there is
no specifics about business and it just
seemed like it was clear that it was
clear that it was part of the daily
conversations that Hunter Biden had with
his father
and it was and and sounded like most of
the time uh
now President Biden didn't even know who
the people he was at dinner he was just
asked to say hello uh and he would you
know talk about the the way he described
it several times they asked over and
over and over he described what the
weather was how uh how what's going on
on your end he the the witness was very
very consistent that none of those
conversations ever had to do with any
business dealings or transactions they
were purely what he called casual
conversation how
now that story fell apart after Devin
Archer revealed that Joe didn't just pop
in on a call or two happened to be
walking by something like that but that
Joe was actually present on more than 20
of Hunter's crooked business calls wow
what are the odds a lot of coincidences
which means
that either Joe Biden has a lot of very
strong opinions on the weather or that
he was actively involved in Hunter's
business which has now led to the
Democrats latest story
which has now fully transformed from
Biden was not and would never have been
involved in Hunter's crooked business
deals to
of course Biden was involved as well he
should be
contradict the president's statements
saying that he never talked to any of
Hunter by the business associates
clearly he talked whether it's about the
weather or whatever but he said
specifically that he's never talked to
them doesn't this contradict I don't
know what his comment is and if we're
gonna well I don't I don't think that's
what he said he never said that he has
never spoken to anyone he said that he
had nothing to do with Hunter Biden's
business dealings if he says hello to
someone that he sees his son with what
is he supposed to say hi son oh no I'm
not going to say hello to the other
people at the table or the other people
on the phone it's kind of a Preposterous
premise to think that a father should
not say hello to people that the Sun or
at dinner with the son is at dinner with
and that is literally all the evidences
and so I mean what was Joe Biden going
to do what was he going to do not talk
to Hunter about his business dealings
like he said
or what or not say hello to Hunter's
crook friends at dinner or what not get
on over 20 phone calls with Hunter and
the Crux that they were shaking down for
millions of dollars in exchange for
American influence what do you think Joe
Biden is honest
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
the new snow white lady she's she's sand
beige
she's
she's Sandy taupe or something she is uh
going off about how Snow White is
extremely dated we will get to not just
the Snow White controversy but what it
means for something to be dated in our
day and age first though I don't want to
move on too quickly past the ukrainians
not only the ones who paid the Biden's
millions and millions of dollars but the
ukrainians who are trying to drag us
into World War III
hey Vladimir zielinski the leader of
Ukraine
has now declared that it is absolutely
fair to bring the war in Ukraine to the
Russian Homeland
this is in the wake of another drone
attack on Moscow Solinski says
absolutely fair for his forces to attack
targets within the Russian Mainland okay
yeah maybe
maybe it's fair Russia invaded Ukraine
after all right so it's fair for the
ukrainians to defend themselves and to
take the war to the Russians isn't it
yeah maybe maybe it is
whose weapons is zielinski going to be
using to carry out those attacks
is it going to be his weapons
that he bought and that he built and
that he's fun no it's going to be our
weapons
and so
the question that we have to ask
zelinski and the rest of the world is
do we want
Ukraine
to be using our weapons and our money
since we are the only reason that
Ukraine has been able to continue this
war past week two do we want
our military assets being used to wage a
war on the homeland of a nuclear former
superpower
something that we managed to avoid for
the entirety of the Cold War
post World War II we've now got nuclear
weapons in play we managed to avoid this
for the very very tense Cold War for the
second half of the 20th century and now
this punk in Ukraine is demanding and
has been demanding month after month
after month that we the funders of his
side of the war
but squander all of that and get into a
hot firing war on the Russian Mainland
for what for what
what's the goal what is the U.S interest
here and what is the goal
do we do we want regime change in Russia
why why do you know who's going to come
after Putin
do do we have any evidence whatsoever
that deposing Vladimir Putin will make
the situation any better and will help
the United States no why so that Ukraine
can maintain its territorial boundaries
from when from
2020 from
2014 from when we're talking about a
Thousand-Year territorial conflict here
why so that the zelinski government can
remain in power do we I don't care about
Vladimir zielinski at all
why why would we why would we follow
this guy into World War Three it
guaranteed if the United States is
waging a war on the Russian Mainland
we're just in World War Three
why would we do that well because it's
fair I don't want to hear about fair
from Vladimir zielinski if fair means
that we're going to end up in a global
very likely nuclear Conflict for who
knows how many years what I would like
to do is
wind the war down which is going to
require concessions from both sides
it's going to require some diplomacy
it's going to have to require accepting
the real political circumstances not
just slogans and idealism and little
blue and yellow flags and Twitter
handles
and as always it's going to require
prayer and when you are looking for ways
to improve your prayer life perhaps you
ought to check out hello right now head
on over to hallow.com Knowles it is
clear that the libs are giving up their
morals in any common sense I'm not sure
they ever had any there's no better time
to build a daily habit of prayer and
meditation building a habit of prayer
can help you cultivate an attitude of
gratitude focusing on what you are
thankful for can increase positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
but the main reason to pray and meditate
is because it's an obligation that you
owe to God hallo is the number one
Christian prayer rap in the United
States it has helped a ton of people
maintain a daily prayer routine and it
can help you too download the app for
free at hallow.com
you can set prayer reminders track your
progress along the way not sure where to
start check out father Mike schmitz's
Bible in a year available on the Hallow
app for brief daily readings and
reflections
or pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes with hallow you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
right now download Hello at hallow.com
Knowles kwles get an exclusive three
months for free that is three months
absolutely free at hallow.com Knowles
speaking of questioning our leader as
presidential candidate Nikki Haley
has a suggestion
for a way to improve our political order
and that would be mental competency
tests for the old guys running the show
when I was talking about the
grandchildren what I was saying is that
we need to have term limits in Congress
and we need to have mental competency
tests for anyone over the age of 75 and
I don't say that to be disrespectful
when you go and you look at buying and
you and you ask him what country he was
in the week before and he can't say it
when you go and ask him how many
grandchildren he has and he doesn't know
when you go and see him falling asleep
with leaders that's concerning that is
concerning and I really like Nikki Haley
personally uh this is not a good idea
because we already have a mental
competency test for all of our
politicians of every age and that
competency test is called an election
and the competency test takes place at
The Ballot Box
and I'm sure many people share this this
view that Joe Biden is way too old
doesn't really seem like Trump is too
old even though Trump is quite up there
in terms of age you know as he described
himself he's a young virile vigorous man
uh but Biden can barely State his own
name he wanders around he doesn't know
which end is up
nevertheless we have a competency test
it's called an election we should
probably make sure that our elections
are uh legit that our elections actually
reflect the desires of Voters and not
the people who want to Tinker with them
but if we were to add some new
qualification
for the presidency on top of the
Constitutional limits all that would do
is empower the tinkerers and the
bureaucrats and the Deep Staters and the
careerists and the staffers
there is a reason
why the Constitution sets up fairly
minimal requirements to run for office
and that's to prevent the people who are
in power publicly or behind the scenes
from keeping fresh blood out of the
system
the fact that we don't have these little
tests added to the requirements is why
Donald Trump could run for president
from prison
because the Congress doesn't have the
right to impose more restrictions on
what it takes to run for president than
the framers of our constitution did
I'm not denying that there's a problem
with Joe Biden not being able to speak
and being the president of the United
States the solution to that is not going
to be to further empower the tinkerers
and social engineers in the Deep Staters
and the clever behind the scenes people
who played a big role in installing
Biden in the first place speaking of
presidential candidates
Rolling Stone is wrong again
isn't that surprising Rolling Stone has
this headline desantises donors want
more than a reboot they want him to
clean house some of the governor's
backers see a staff that is too online
but others are starting to ask if the
real problem is DeSantis himself you
might recall I happen to remember that a
rolling stone was one of the first
Outlets to brazenly libel me after my
CPAC speech and say that I said
something that I didn't say and
eventually they had to back down I
assume because their lawyers made them
so the Rolling Stone is not known for
its high journalistic standards but here
what's wrong is not that they've liled
anybody it's just a typically
brain dead take on politics everyone is
trying to begin the post-mortem of the
DeSantis campaign even though we're
still early on in DeSantis still has a
shot to get the nomination and so
they're all trying to figure out what
went wrong
is it his staffers oh if only he had
different staffers that's the problem
now rolling stone because they the
liberal journalists hate to say this
personally so oh maybe it's just
DeSantis himself he's too stiff he's not
likable he's this he's that whatever
guys you're overthinking it
you're overthinking this
Rhonda Santos's staff is fine
Rhonda Santos is a very strong candidate
obviously he's an extremely talented
politician he's good governor of Florida
he's
number two in the polls at least for now
and even as his campaign has begun to
falter he started out really a very
strong number two in the polls now as
he's failed to move up and take on
number one you're seeing another
candidate for fake ramaswamy start to
creep up there on him too but in any
other cycle
Ron DeSantis would be the clear away
front runner in this race
and everyone would be praising his staff
and everybody would be talking about how
he's a generational brilliant candidate
and no one can touch him the problem for
DeSantis is not the staff it's not the
donors it's not the candidate it's
Donald Trump Donald Trump who is a once
in a generation political Talent who is
running for all intents and purposes as
the incumbent in this race because Trump
seeking a non-consecutive second term is
something that none of us has seen in
our lifetime we haven't seen it since
1888.
and
Trump
you maybe you hate him maybe you love
him
he is a once in a generation political
Talent
he won the highest office in the land
without ever having held any public
office whatsoever including dog catcher
he won the highest office in the land
the first time that he fully pulled the
trigger on running he had flirted with
running for a long time but the first
time he ever really pulled the trigger
ever really ran an Earnest campaign he
won
he's a major political Talent
he attracted people to the GOP that no
one has attracted since Ronald Reagan
he maybe put some people off too he
maybe lost the 2020 election
maybe he didn't but maybe he did maybe
he did and maybe he allowed the
political circumstances to spiral out of
control such that they were able to
change all of the election laws in the
weeks and months before the election and
and steal it from him people are always
trying to steal elections especially the
libs and so maybe you say well I blame
Trump even if they did steal it I blame
Trump for letting them steal it okay
blah blah blah whatever maybe you hate
the guy maybe you hate the guy but you
cannot deny he is an American original
we have not seen a politician like him
in our lifetimes we haven't seen a
politician like him in 100 years at
least
that's desantis's problem
that's it that's all it comes down to
you don't need to blame the guy and say
he's always a terrible politician oh
he's a deep State Rhino establishment
he's none of those things oh his staff
they're just uniquely terrible they're
not the staff is fine
the problem is now and always was the
unique circumstance of Donald Trump
running in 2024.
if there is going to be a postmortem and
again
DeSantis could still get the nomination
we don't know what is going to happen in
the next
few months
they're going to indict Trump in every
all 57 states that Barack Obama
recognized they're gonna they're gonna
indict Trump on planet Mars
who knows but if there is going to be a
post-mortem
everyone's going to try to express facto
discover all sorts of things about the
DeSantis campaign and the candidate and
blah blah blah guys it's just Trump it's
just it's been about Trump for seven
years and a lot of people want to deny
his uniqueness as an American political
figure and they do that to their own
detriment and to the effect of writing
really silly tanks that that do not get
to the truth here so Trump is
capitalizing on his huge lead I mean one
poll has him up at like 54 in the GOP
Primary not only
double digits way ahead of his Rivals
but more than 50 percent of the of the
primary voters Trump is capitalizing on
this and he's calling for other
candidates to drop out
every dollar spent attacking me by
Republicans is a dollar given straight
to the Biden campaign if he makes it I
don't know if he's going to make it who
thinks he's going to be the candidate
every dollar spent attacking me is a
dollar given to Biden and he and he says
he says the other candidates they need
to drop out of this race
and I see why Trump would say that
especially now while he's flying high in
the polls
but the political reality is there is no
reason for DeSantis to drop out of this
race DeSantis has already killed himself
and killed any shots that he's got being
appointed in a trump Administration
that's over he'll get if if Trump
approaches him at all if Trump somehow
becomes the president and approaches him
at all he'll get the Mitt Romney
treatment he'll play around with him
like a cat with catnip so DeSantis the
the die is cast he's just got to keep
running Pence same thing what what else
is Pence going to do he's he has no
reason to get out of the race Christy
he's got no reason to get out of the
race he's come out against Trump too
what's his political future nothing so
he's going to stay in the race same with
Vivek
the vague for a little different reason
though Vivek hasn't really gone after
Trump they came out of nowhere came out
of left field and he has proved himself
to be an extremely
compelling
political Talent
who would have thought that some Yale
law
Pharma guy who's a Hindu with the name
ramaswamy would become a major player
could very soon become the number two
guy in the GOP race that tells you that
this guy's got a message that is
resonating that he's really really sharp
and that he's a very strong political
Talent
so he's going to continue to prove
himself in that field especially if he
doesn't keep going after Trump or
doesn't hit Trump too hard he's got all
the reason to stay in the race the rest
of the candidates probably ought to drop
out if they want to roll in a potential
Trump Administration that's true but at
least for one two three four candidates
there's no reason for them to get out
yet which means we're going to have some
debates when you want to debate issues
with your friends you got to check out
pure talk right now head on over to
puretalk.com Knowles you know a company
is looking out for you and they actually
upgrade your service and don't charge
you for it this is great news for new
and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but have not made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you'll get unlimited talk
text and now 50 more 5G data plus their
new mobile hotspot this is why I love
Pure Talk they're veteran owned and they
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great U.S of a
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America remember you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you go to puretalk.com save an
additional fifty percent five zero
percent off your first month because
they value you that is puretalk.com
Knowles Pure Talk Wireless for Americans
by Americans when Dr Jordan B Peterson
made the decision to join daily wire
plus it was a major win for people who
Champion intellectual debate with one
year of unparalleled output his
contributions have set new standards and
remained unmatched by any other platform
daily wire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan content offering
hundreds of hours of captivating content
you will not find anywhere else Jordan
has created thought-provoking works that
reshape your perspective on a life which
include vision and Destiny marriage and
dragons and Monsters and Men and a lot
of other things that we can add in a
series of parentheses and commas
Additionally you can immerse yourself in
discussions that nurture your spiritual
side such as logos and literacy and
Jordan's groundbreaking series on the
book of Exodus that's only the beginning
I have not even mentioned his Beyond
order lecture series or his extensive
Archive of lectures and podcasts this is
the compendium of all things Jordan plus
there's even more new exclusive content
on the horizon
this is only the beginning by becoming a
daily wire plus member you will embark
on an unforgettable experience that will
fuel your thirst for knowledge and
Inspire personal growth like never
before go to dailywire.com subscribe to
become a member
today
speaking of knocking people out
this the Congress is trying to Tinker
with the Supreme Court they've been
trying to pack the court for a long time
now they're trying to get the judges to
recuse themselves from all sorts of
cases only the conservative judges of
course now they're trying to attack
the character of the conservative judges
they've been doing that with Clarence
Thomas for 30 years now they're
especially focusing in on Sam Alito
because Sam Alito wrote the opinion in
the Dobbs case that overturned the fake
right to abortion in America so they're
going after Alito
and they're threatening they're saying
if the Supreme Court conservatives don't
adopt a particular code of ethics that
we want them to adopt and then we're
going to impose it on the Supreme Court
which is leading us to our latest
constitutional crisis and once again Sam
Alito absolute rock star of a jurist
comes out
and he says
no
and he doesn't just say no we're not
going to do this he says a really
important observation it says Congress
has no right
to regulate the Supreme Court
no right specifically to force the
Supreme Court to adopt some code of
ethics the Supreme Court does not
ultimately answer to the Congress
he notes quote Congress did not create
the Supreme Court the Constitution did
said I know this is a controversial view
but I'm willing to say it no provision
in the Constitution gives them the
authority to regulate the Supreme Court
period I really like that Justice Alita
made this point in particular because I
made this point a week ago and I'm glad
that someone who knows what he's talking
about agrees with me you never know I
don't know I didn't go to law school
I've never argued a case before The
Supreme Court but I made the same point
said if the Congress asserts this
control over the Supreme Court one how
are they going to enforce it are you
going to get
Nancy Pelosi to go hobble over to the
Supreme Court and start you know
haranguing the justices I don't think so
but two
this would create a constitutional
crisis
you know sometimes this is a little out
of left field but it'll loop back
I have
joked
is it a joke about the Jacobite line of
succession I've said that it was a very
terrible thing in English political
history when William and Mary of orange
came over from the Netherlands and took
the throne from James II James II who
became king he was the last Catholic
monarch of England and he became king
after Charles II died Charles II was a
Protestant and he had a deathbed
conversion to Catholicism and this
created a crisis because a lot of the
Protestants were not happy about a
Catholic Monarch so what happened
this is what happened I've got all sorts
of views on the Jacobite line of
succession and what it means today and
who's The Pretender to the throne and
blah blah blah but that's a topic for
another day the reason that this matters
for American uh politics is the way that
James II was deposed is that Parliament
Parliament
exercised
more Authority than they had
and Parliament established parliamentary
Supremacy to say effectively we get to
pick the Monarch and they booted James
II out and they invited those Protestant
Dutch Interlopers over William and Mary
of orange and installed them on the
throne and forget about the Catholic
versus Protestant debate forget about
the James II versus William and Mary
debate
it's a question of who has the power in
the government
is it going to be a balanced government
are there going to be checks on the
authority of one part of the government
over another part of the government is
it going to be an inversion of the
traditional understanding of that power
does parliament just run the whole show
if
the US Congress
can bring the Supreme Court Justices to
heal then we don't really have three
branches of government we've got it most
too because the Supreme Court will
become a subsidiary of Congress and if
anybody thinks that would be a good
thing in the United States I would
encourage you to open your eyes and take
a look at Congress
speaking of old institutions
very old not just old like the Supreme
Court not just old like the British
Monarchy old like Snow White 1937. the
new Snow White Lady
who is who is notably not white so we
called her sand beige
Sandy Tope
uh this lady is thrilled that they're
remaking Snow White not just in the new
casting decisions but remaking the whole
movie because she says that Snow White
is dated
cartoon was made 85 years ago and
therefore it's
really
ideas of women being in roles of power
and uh and what a woman is fit for in
the world and so when we came to
reimagining the actual role of Snow
White it became about the fairest of
them all meaning who is the most just
and who can become a fantastic leader
and the reality is you know Snow White
has to learn a lot of lessons about
coming into her own power before she can
come into power over a kingdom also the
fact that she's not going to be saved by
The Prince and she's the proactive one
and she's the one who said the terms
um is what makes it so relevant to where
we are today
not even going to comment on the way
that they've Rewritten the script
to take out all those terrible things
like Beauty and love you know who wants
Snow White with beauty and love when we
can talk about girl bosses when isn't
that captivating can't you wait to just
run out to the theaters and get your
popcorn and no I don't think so forget
that for a second
she says they rewrote the story because
Snow White is extremely dated
dated
what does that mean to be dated
she's saying it like it's a bad thing
it's bad to be dated
isn't it only bad
for a thing to be dated
if the time that we're living in is
better than the time that the dated
thing
existed in
in other words
if if we were living in in this
wonderful age where everyone was
thriving and things were beautiful and
just and good and virtuous and and then
you looked back it's at some other time
in history
and you pointed to some Vestige of that
and you said oh that's so dated from
that time and that other time was a
really awful terrible time and where
everything was ugly and decaying and
vicious and evil and
well then then it would be bad for
something to be dated to that time but
what if
the time that we were living in right
now is worse by almost every measure
than the time
to which this thing we're criticizing is
dated then dated would be a good thing
and then we'd say oh that's so dated
from this much better time that can
maybe give us a guide post as to how to
get out of the dumb age that we're
living in
buy virtually every measure by virtually
every measure 1937 was a better time
that was more conducive to human
flourishing and virtue than today is
and and we can look through all the
social scientific data on this
we're not having any kids anymore the
civilization is literally dying people
are much more depressed people are much
more anxious the suicide rates are much
higher people are reporting much lower
rates of happiness and satisfaction you
look at all the social science
and then you look at the harder facts
should we see a little bit in people
we're having bigger families people were
were
building beautiful things the culture
was physically more beautiful you had
better buildings better artwork coming
up yet you had people therefore a little
more hopeful about the future
what you're always going to hear when
you bring that up is people to say yeah
but you know back in the past
separate water fountain
found some sort of unpleasant feature of
the past as I see
and and if in the case of 1937 that's
pretty much it this is before World War
II got the end of the Great Depression
on the horizon and by the way material
hardship is not
not intrinsically immoral or anything
like that but
even then
yeah you say okay well what about that
huh back in back then they had different
water fountains for white and black
people okay now we kill 800 000 babies a
year now we chop little kids genitals
off now we don't have any hope for the
future or any patriotism the rates of
those things are declining precipitously
now we don't have National borders now
we don't speak the same language now we
now we this now we that oh did I mention
we kill 800 000 babies a year you're
really going to tell me oh no we're
living in the best time you just don't
understand this is what the Liberals
always say the Liberals on the left and
even the Liberals on the right
the the kind of center-right people oh
come on let's stop complaining we're
living in the best time they often adopt
the premises and the language of the
left no
1937 America had its act much more
together than it does now
white is dated yeah I guess so let's go
watch that movie maybe we can learn a
thing or two
speaking of signs of the times and
social science
some good news finally
High School boys are becoming more
right-wing this according to a new
survey out from the monitoring the
future survey this is a scholarly
Endeavor that dates back about 50 years
uh the boys are becoming more
conservative
the 12th grade girls are becoming more
liberal
so
good news and bad news Men Are from Mars
Women Are from Venus
but
but the the trend at least for the boys
is in the right direction why is this
happening
I think this is happening in part
because we've destroyed marriage and the
notion that that boys and girls are
complementary so rather than boys and
girls
moving closer and closer together
recognizing how they fit together and uh
is that euphemistic or is that no it's
it's metaphorical as well that that
recognizing that we each have something
to add and men really need women and
women really need men and we're going to
move together and become one flesh and
and be of one mind uh the libs have
destroyed marriage and so when women get
married they become more conservative
when
and and maybe men moderate some of their
extremism too when they stay apart then
they move in opposite directions
this is why a society with a proper
understanding of marriage will be more
conservative and a society that
disregards marriage and abolishes
marriage and redefines it is going to
become more liberal we've just seen that
in real time
also also everyone's going to give their
hot take on why the the young boys are
becoming more conservative right now my
hot take as to why this is happening is
because we're living in a world that is
more virtual
kids are not going out and climbing
trees as much they're not racing fast
cars as much they're not going on
physical Adventures as much the society
is becoming much more
focused on computers and video games and
stay in your apartment and consuming
content and it's just not as vigorous
and physical as it used to be
and so because young boys are inclined
toward extreme behavior and risky
Behavior that's just in our DNA the
the the way that that is instantiated in
this more virtual reality type culture
is going to be through risky and edgy
and controversial intellectual Pursuits
rather than just physical ones that's
why to be a conservative today is to
question and to oppose the entire regime
the entire liberal establishment which
controls every Institution
to do that is risky it's edgy it's
extreme it's counter-cultural it's
rebellious it's all the things that
young men always are but whereas in the
past they would have gone out and smoked
cigarettes and gotten drunk and driven
motorcycles and and I don't know gone
womanizing and
all the surveys show as young men are
not doing that as much as they used to
even with the hookup culture they're
having less sex with fewer women
so all that edginess all that
rebelliousness all that risky Behavior
that's going to be more intellectual
it's going to be more in the life of the
mind and what does that mean in a
culture such as ours in a very liberal
culture it means you become more
right-wing so that's the silver lining
in the storm cloud now my favorite
comment yesterday
is from DC
zelenac060 who says
I am become feminism
destroyer of the family
Barbie 2023
I love that
because in a matter of about four hours
I am going to see Barbie I'm going to
meet up with sweet little Elisa we are
going to watch Barbie
even though it's the middle of the work
day and we're going to do that because
there is a backstage tonight and I know
Ben hates Barbie and so if Ben hates
something I have to assume that I will
like it but I don't know I don't know
I've also heard from a lot of people
that it's terrible I've heard from a lot
of people that it's good I just don't
know I just don't know
what to think about it so I'm gonna go
watch it before backstage we will
discuss we'll have the real debate
forget aliens for a second we'll
probably have to talk about that too but
we'll have the real debate that it's
roiling the daily wire we will discuss
Barbie
speaking of the extreme behavior of
young men probably can't include this
part on YouTube today
it is it is
[Music]
speaking of things people shouldn't be
doing
dog meat farmers in South Korea are
pushing back on a potential ban South
Korea wants to ban dog meat
I don't like dogs
I don't some people ask are you a dog
person are you a cat person I'm not I'm
a people person I like people
I don't really care for pets that much I
don't hate them I don't they don't make
me angry but I just don't like them
and yet
people should not eat dog Libs think we
should be able to eat dogs utilitarians
think we ought to be able to eat dogs
materialists think we ought to be able
to eat dogs because you know it's just
meat these people probably think we
should eat humans
but we should not eat dogs
and the reason it's wrong to eat dogs
and the reason the South Korean dog
farmers are wrong and the reason that
the people trying to reform this are
right is because that's not what dogs
are for
dogs are there to be man's best friend
they're not my best friend but broadly
they are a man's best friend they were
bred to be man's best friend
and that's why it's especially cruel in
a way that it's not cruel to kill a
needed cow killing a pig killing it a
chicken
the dogs are there and we're bred even
if you just want to look at a purely
historical evolutionary kind of view of
it to say nothing of a deeper
philosophical View they're there to be
our mate and our help and our buddies
and our Companions and it's wrong to eat
them that's why that's why it feels
wrong to eat a dog I've never tried
eating a dog but that's why I would not
be inclined to eat a dog even though I
don't like them all that much
it's the C.S Lewis argument for it it's
not that dogs have rights they don't
it's not that animals have rights
broadly they don't
but when we when we do things like
torture animals or when we do things
like eat dogs
it deadens our Humanity because we are
violating a kind of
metaphysical Concord that we have with
with dogs and we're violating the proper
order of Nature and and the ends to
which these things are ordered okay
Tuesday now that I've just done probably
what's effectively a three-minute show
on YouTube today because of my
digression into the Mr Beast guy uh we
will get into Tuesday that's the day uh
for the member block we can't talk about
it on YouTube so you've got to head on
over if you're a member of the Hawaii
and you're not watching on daily wire
plus then you've got to come over right
now go to dailywire.com use code Knowles
and check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign